o funziona la madonna l'amato youtube
ragazzi su tecnologia tecnologia
incredibile ma veramente funziona sta
roba da ora scusatemi raga ma è la prima
volta nella vita che faccio una live
devo disattivare i commenti perché siete
talmente tanti che tanto non riuscire
comunque a vederli tutti quindi
scusatemi
comunque voglio dirvi che questa è la
prima raid che faccio cosa fighissima
tra l'altro ciao ciao belli allora
allora vi spiego questa cosa molto
divertente ci siete
nella specie a quanti cazzo siete 10.000
c'è questo momento io sto parlando a
10.000 persone
il momento di risplendere quindi devo
dire qualcosa di intelligente chiba
la patata a patata viva la patata in
inglese di vallà chips di vela chips
ragazzi sempre e comunque
comunque vi spiego che cazzo è successa
una cosa divertentissima allora in
realtà io sono venuto qui a londra
perché c'era appunto questa cosa delle
live che non andrò a fare altre quattro
in questi giorni quindi cliccate sulla
campanella qua sotto così via non per
caso quando vado in live tipo adesso
tanto siete in 30mila questa cosa non mi
sta mettendo per l'infanzia comunque la
cosa di vertigini successa è che io sto
qua una settimana no però la nintendo mi
ha chiamato per andare a vedere il
lancio della nintendo switch che la
nuova console e quindi sono venuta a
londra prima con email con lorenzo con
mio zio antonio culo barbuto bello e in
poche parole che cosa è successo tre
domani arrivano i miei genitori ok solo
che antonio e tutti gli altri anche i
mezzi sono andati via prima
quindi io in questo momento sarà a
londra da solo non c'è nessuno ci sono
in un altro in un altro pianeta
praticamente completamente da solo c'è
l'unica persona che conosco più vicino
a me sta in italia che è un po distante
l'italia vicino ad abbiategrasso quel
paese
comunque io sono a londra da solo sono
addirittura in uno specchio a londra da
solo bellissimo comunque ragazzi a parte
strizzata che è stata quanto fino a
domani pomeriggio sarò da solo quindi ho
deciso di andare in live così invece di
essere da solo o 32mila persone che mi
vado lì diretta e vita comunque
non a parte questo vi faccio vedere la
cosa più della terra che questo
posto allora in realtà magari se non mi
inquadrano i tre secondi da dietro è
meglio così questo blog è stato più il
protagonista della te la mia schiena non
sono io
vi spiego allora siamo in questo hotel
che tra l'altro vicinissimo al big ben
praticamente adesso ci andiamo adesso
esco dalla stanza mi vesto perché fuori
ci sono meno 20 gradi io sono così se
esco così in tempo due secondi diventò
un po la retto e vi faccio vedere un
attimino come la stanza che abbastanza
non avete visto e 300 volte hanno
fatto avanti e indietro mini non sto a
farvi vedere di là vi faccio vedere il
cesso che c'è la vasca che è fittissima
perché a casa non solo l'alaska
la doccia mentre ti fai la vasca
prendere anche a fatti la doccia
un altro specchio che non abbiamo ancora
visti gli specchi oggi il sesso che
magari non in quadro perché ho accesso
non inquadriamo perché fatto le cose so
se prima comunque vi spiego questa roba
allora siamo in un hotel vicinissimo al
big ben adesso mi vesto e andiamo al big
bang tutti quanti insieme ok porto 30
mila persone in diretta big ben
se ci siete ci andiamo allora terminati
ma che devo vestirmi che sono come cazzo
si mette stato qua allora vi lascio un
secondo è che vi lascio che devo
vestirmi un attimo mi lascia in bella
compagnia tanti like per questa bella
che ci avevo sul tavolo bene arrivo
è che devo mettermi le robe allora di
fatto è che stare a londra da solo è
fighissimo perché posso fare il cazzo
che voglio
mi spiego mi sento un sacco come non mi
ricordo come si chiama l'attore però
quello di mamma ho perso l'aereo perché
precisamente quando tornano i miei
genitori con ci sarà un casino perché io
stasera butto tutto all'aria tipo sasha
e tra l'altro messo la fede non sapevo
che felpa a mettermi oggi allora ho
messo questa è già scritto boy london
qua moda la moda poi non capite insomme
i cechi enzo miccio chi cazzo è questa
io ci devo essere sulla copertina non la
glamour
questa è glamour non capii non capite
niente comunque vi racconto cosa è
successo quando siamo arrivati all'hotel
è stato tragico alimento prima questo
sono veramente crepo di freddo
allora siamo arrivati a questo te che vi
ripeto apprendimenti di fianco dove lo
scaldacollo che sono crepe
eccolo non mi chiedete perché c'è uno
scaldacollo sopra il sesso perché non lo
so neanch'io aspetta un attimo
ok siamo praticamente la chiave che se
poi non entro più perfetto e vabbè si
spegne tutto spiega aiuta non sapere la
porta sono pedico no fermi non ci posso
credere come cazzo fatto qua a chiedere
la porta questi meccanismi
porca eva non potevamo usare la chiave
caccia vacca nicchia saw l'enigmista ciò
la chiave no su cat
salve salve facciata ciao bella perfetta
special guest del video comunque vi
spiego questa cosa siamo arrivati in
questo hotel che adesso vi faccio vedere
a tutti quanti tutte le persone che mi
seguono da londra domani sono qua sotto
a far raduno io l'ho già lo so questo
vabbè lasciamo verde
arriviamo tel entriamo tutti contenti io
e mio zio
abbiamo riservato una stanza
all'hotel questo qua no
ditemi il nome e cognome e faccio
lorenzo ostuni barola e mi fanno ok
l'hotel non è questo ma siccome non è
questo ciao e mi hanno detto l'hotel è
quello di fianco
l'hotel di fianco allo stesso nome
stesso nome di questo senso fai fare due
hotel vicini con lo stesso nome
l'hotel di prima entriamo una figata
pazzesca subentrato detto no non ci
posso credere
questo si sta chiedendo che lingua sto
parlando sicuro niente per la mente alla
fine siamo venuti in questo hotel
entriamo e c'è quella portali che non è
automatica ma la devi spingere quindi
già questa per poveri hashtag poveri
prima cosa andiamo alla reception lì
quella la reception
andiamo alla reception ci fermano a me e
mio zio
se io sette ragazzini di dieci anni tipo
e mi fanno a me oddio ma tu sei 6 lo
youtuber così mi ha pestato sto
spingendo viva i poveri ma tu sei lo
youtuber mi fanno e io sì sono io ma dai
ti segue sempre sul tuo canale sei un
grande e dexter
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ve lo giuro su dio ve lo giuro è
successo veramente questo mi fanno sei
un grande e dexter se veramente un
grande ti seguo sempre facile e bello
zio allora iscriviti al mio canale non
sapevano dexter poi mette anche mi piace
ciccio game tanto dice vabbè allora qua
siamo fuori ragazzi questo è l'autobus
di harry potter
solo che non c'è reporter anzi facciamo
così guarda dovrei averci in tasca
questi che in realtà poi tratto il mio
zio è talmente alto che sembra grid
quindi oggi sembrava di andare in giro
con hagrid per londra e stato bellissimo
ha spinto gli occhiali lame kazemi
espressa espresso per hogwarts maledetti
salve signora allora siamo in 40mila in
line cosa pazzesca youtube sarà
contentissimo
il meno male perché una live molto
interessante questa e adesso andiamo al
big bang
andiamo tutti quanti addebitato sta
piovendo ma non lo vedete
però non ci sia bordello è perché c'è un
po di traffico aver normale però è
distante dieci metri ma io lo so già che
riuscirò a perdermi lo so io lo so
allora no perché se io sono io quando
vado a comprare il latte fuori da casa
mia
rischio di morire a quella del london
eye cola con la london eye fatevi
guardare dall'altra parte della strada
perché questi guidano al contrario
perché ci hanno il volante dall'altra
parte un macello non capisco mai una
sega
ok cancellami sta ammazzando allora
stavo dicendo c'è london eye da quella
parte lì è il big ben e da questa parte
quello che vi dico che io in genere
quando esco di casa a milano
faccio 2 metri poi mi perdo pensate come
cazzo sto messo io a londra da solo fa
veramente ridere il cazzo sta ricordo la
vetta comunque
allora passiamo dalle tre pieno di
autobus pieno bellissima sta roba
in questo momento dovrei controllare su
google maps dove fottutamente stasto big
ben
però non non posso farlo perché se lo
faccio la live mi va a
ora quello che corre torri questo vuole
apparire nella live ha fame di fama
[Musica]
ciao zio vabbè 2 che bisogna andare
eccolo ci siamo non mi sono perso non ci
posso credere
siete pronti a ga festa si fa le unghie
siete pronti ragazzi pronti a te lo
faccio vedere dopo non adesso che
toglierà abbastanza lontano attraversa
la strada e poi ve lo faccio vedere che
bella no andrà mi piace un sacco vi
giuro
il fatto di essere da solo e ancora più
figo perché veramente mi sento troppo
indipendente poi domani muoio
però non so come si mangia da solo non è
l'idea come si fa in un ristorante si
chiede un tavolo lo fanno sempre gli
altri per me lo fa mia mamma perché io
non sono capace
ora che figo paralitica sta roba e tra
l'altro questa era l'acquisterà l'hotel
che vi dicevo prima quello che ha lo
stesso nome era questo che sto tell ha
lo stesso nome del mio è un metro ma
puoi veramente mentre lasciamo perdere
[Musica]
ma il bello che la tipa ci fa si è un
errore che fanno spesso vengono qua
perché credono sia questo e quell'altro
e grazie a cazzo cioè che lo stesso nome
maledizione io con questa parte di
londra veramente veramente
perché c'è in realtà londra è sempre un
po grigia know kow infatti ha piovuto
tutto il giorno però anche da grigia
anche da piovosa al suo fascino londra
dopo tipo mi infilo in una mischia
autobus anche se non devo andare da
nessuna parte
solo per vedere come dentro allora
signori io vi faccio vedere questa cosa
me la faccio vedere adesso e poi ci
avviciniamo un po di più ok dei pronti
è leggermente piccolo però è perché
lontano grazie alla mente adesso ci
avviciniamo però è veramente figo cioè
avere l'hotel a un metro dal big ben e
veramente figo infatti a ecco quando mai
detto che l'hotel non era questo ho
detto no mica ci manderanno in culo ai
lupi invece no era vicino anche l'altro
queste sono le
cioè se lei è questa e l'iphone 8
l'iphone 8 prego prego signor
e veramente fissato possono entrare
a figo sono dentro non ci posso credere
adesso faccio come doctor boom
verificata la funziona non si cose sono
per bellezza ma io rimango qua ragazzi
dispiace ma è una figata
volevo farvi vedere come era dentro uno
di sti cosi
dunque non sa roba delle lei è veramente
bella ragazza il problema è che non sono
abituato a farlo quindi parlare davanti
a 30mila persone non è facile perché
quando faccio vita è un altro conto
perché li taglio e tutto quando li
faccio in diretta un'altra roba
perché se tipo mi succedeva ci fosse
sbatto contro un muro faccio una figura
di merda in live e ste robe a me
succedono spesso
altra roba tra l'altro oggi a quasi
straripato tutto il tamigi qualche ha
piovuto come come cristo comanda fatti
volevo bloggare in quel punto poi ha
detto no va bene se muoio facciale views
ma non riesco a caricare il video
quindi ho detto a brescia perde però
sarebbe stato figure se vi faccio vedere
come il tamigi
siete pronti che sta veramente figo here
we go
screenate che mi faccio la copertina di
facebook grazie
bene massa
si si lo so non ridere non ridere sono
così anche nella normalità io normalità
tra virgolette dopo ci siamo
secondo me i soldi in giro con gli
occhiali da harry potter a milano mi
riconosce nessuno frequente figo london
eye peas in chianti
io vi giuro ragazzina ho mai visto una
cosa così grossa ciao
che faccia aveva così va beh
ok siamo sul ponte prima del london eye
si del big ben visti taxi ti dissi una
volta mi deve passare davanti mister
bean manca solo quello contano veramente
se prendeva un hotel più in centro di
questo cazzo finiva nella tazzina del tè
della reggina minchia centrare il
massimo poi domani se qualcuno mi sta
seguendo ed è di londra o se domani c'è
il raduno sotto l'hotel cambio tel
ok che già mi citofonano a casa
mortacci ci manca solo questo infatti
non dovevo farla live prove sticazzi
allora ancora due tre metri questo è il
massimo di camminata che io posso fare
nella mia vita e non farò mai più una
camminata così è già troppo già troppo
movimento in genere mi muovo dal
computer al cesso e viceversa e basta
quindi va già bene così
porcaccia vacca fa un freddo porco rega
poi io che son magro soffro il freddo
come non so cosa ponte più lungo della
storia
comunque sia oggi ho fatto minecraft è
stato veramente figo fare minecraft
perché tutta la gente che mi scrivo
addio ma fa vincesse di giocare a
mancare è sì grazie al caso tu non eri
nato quando giocava minecraft io cazzo
voi ogni volta mi tolgo gli occhiali non
è come rimettere di governo io sono
probabilmente quando finirò sta la juve
c'è però il braccio atrofizzato perchè
il freddo veramente incredibile sarà
freezzato tutto il braccio ciao ci siamo
allora io direi che siamo arrivati
ragazzi
siamo arrivati è questo
e l'iphone 9
l'iphone non è un orologio facciamo che
lo swatch 9
ora che fini è la parte più bella di una
città che io abbia mai visto non mai
visto una non c'è mai non c'è mai stata
una zona così bella in una città che c'è
troppa roba tutta insieme lascia il
london eye la cia il big ben
macef a vj tutte ste tre meraviglie
messi insieme
il ragazzo le trovi bellissimo stupendo
veramente figo mi ricordo assassin's
creed perché ho giocato la demo la
previdente qua era veramente figo il big
ben e veramente figo non so come mai
attraverso il telefono sembra più
piccolo però in realtà veramente e
grosso c'è l'orologio grosso e più
grosso più grosso dei normali orologi
barcaccia vacca va bene dunque questo è
quanto ragazzi io adesso non riuscirò
mai più a tornare a casa ma questo non
me lo faccio vedere perché già
abbastanza ridicolo così gli ho fatto
vedere più o meno dove siamo questi
giorni inserisco a salire sulla london
eye magari faccio una live da lì che mi
sembra molto molto carino e ora gavi vi
lascio qualche tanto non so che cosa
andrò a fare stasera perché vi ripeto
sono da solo e io da solo non ci sono
assolutamente stare
niente ossa suonando è arrivata la mia
ora screenate anche questo che site
fighissimo sono pieno di foto dopo
questa live grazie mille di avermi
seguito ragazzi grazie mille di esser di
avermi fatto compagnia mentre mi stavo
perdendo non ci siamo persi non ci siamo
persi e questo è un grandissimo
traguardo per me
no problem mail
e niente io vi lascio qua raga spero che
vi sia piaciuto consenso mio avviso un
momento è un mi piace anche ai vari
social che come non li vedo tutta una
descrizione io adesso vado a fare di
nuovo e poi vado a mangiare si spera in
dio di non finire nei peugeot sobborghi
di londra e niente
cio dopo il vibrio chiudo con il big
bang big bang dio mio come farlo
chiudo colpi ben ragazzi ci vediamo in
un prossimo video bella
il numero in radio